bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne un débat sur le suivi des
positions européennes du sénat
parmi elles étaient même abordé
aujourd'hui les profils nutritionnels
mais également la question du vin rosé
puis je vous retrouve à partir de 11h30
pour l'événement politique de cette
matinée vous pourrez suivre en direct
sur public sénat la conférence de presse
conjointe à nicolas sarkozy et à angela
merkel bonne matinée à tous l'ordre du
jour appelle le débat européen sur le
suivi des positions européennes du sénat
je vous rappelle que le thème le débat
sera organisé autour de deux thèmes
profil nutritionnel et vin rosé
chacun de ces sujets donnera lieu à un
échange j'indique au sénat que compte
tenu de l'organisation du débat décidé
par la conférence des présidents pour
chacun des deux projets interviendront
le représentant de la commission
compétente ou de la commission des
affaires européennes pour dix minutes
le gouvernement pour dix minutes plus
une discussion spontanée interactive
sera ouverte pour une durée maximum de
20 minutes sous la forme de questions
réponses de 2 minutes maximum par
intervenant dans le cadre du débat sur
les profils nutritionnels la parole est
à monsieur jean bizet jean bizet il ne
saurait tarder jean bizet le voilà au
nom de la commission des affaires
économiques
puis monsieur luc chatel secrétaire
d'état chargé de l'industrie de la
consommation qui chef chez nous
maintenant de là sont permanentes
monsieur visé à vous
l'auteur gilbert récupère la ned toi ça
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la commission des affaires économiques a
adopté une proposition de résolution
concernant les profils nutritionnels
pour les denrées alimentaires règlement
communautaire de décembre 2006 a établi
un cadre harmonisé pour le marché
intérieur destiné à garantir la loyauté
des allégations nutritionnelles
c'est à dire la communication
commerciale sur les caractéristiques
nutritionnelles des produits
alimentaires il s'agissait d'assurer la
bonne information du consommateur en
interdisant par exemple pour des
produits très sucré ou très gras des
mentions publicitaires ou valorisés sur
les emballages du type est riche en fer
ou apport en vitamines ou encore allégés
en selle l'idée était d'éviter que les
industriels de l'agroalimentaire
n'induisent en erreur les consommateurs
sur les caractéristiques nutritionnelles
réel des aliments en insistant sur un
point positif et en restant très discret
sur les aspects plus négatif aussant
sanitaire des produits pour en appliquer
cette réglementation 2006 encore faut-il
définir le profil nutritionnel de ces
aliments
c'est à dire leur proportion en
nutriments que l'on juge acceptable ne
suffit pas de dire ce produit est trop
gras ou trop saleh pour qu'il puisse
faire de la publicité sur ces apports en
calcium
encore faut-il définir exactement en
quoi il est trop gras ou trop salé c'est
pourquoi il est nécessaire
par catégories de produits d'établir des
profils fixant les proportions maximum
de sucre de sel sodium d'acides gras
saturés d'acides gras trans et c'est à
respecter pour être autorisés à faire
des allégations nutritionnelles
cette définition des profils
nutritionnels doit faire l'objet d'un
règlement communautaire d'exécution qui
en raison de son caractère normalement
essentiellement technique est adopté par
la commission européenne sous le
contrôle du conseil et du parlement
européen dans le cadre d'une procédure
dite de comitologie sous l'égide de la
direction générale de la santé des
consommateurs la dg sanco comité
d'experts représentant les 27 états
membres qu'on appelle
cp casa fait ainsi réunis au cours de
l'année 2008 pour fixer par catégorie de
produits alimentaires les seuls de
nutriments définissant leurs profils
spécifiques
or dans ce cp casa se sont affrontées
deux philosophies correspondant à deux
modèles alimentaires
pour schématiser les britanniques et les
pays nordiques d'un côté pour lesquels
la bonne santé de la population et en
particulier la lutte contre le surpoids
et l'obésité est essentiellement assurée
par le contenu nutritionnel des aliments
de l'autre un groupe de pays
continentaux la france l'allemagne
l'espagne l'italie la belgique et les
pays bas qui estime que celle équilibre
alimentaire globale qui est déterminant
et que celui ci est assurée par le
respect de bonnes habitudes
par exemple manger à heures fixes varier
la nourriture avoir des apports
quotidiens en fruits et légumes frais et
c'est comme la dg sanco est plus
perméable aux premiers modèles ces
travaux ont abouti à un projet de
règlement fixant des normes assez
stricte pour les profils est tellement
strictes pour certains qu'elle
interdisait à la quasi-totalité de
quelques catégories de produits de tous
droits
allégations nutritionnelles c'était en
particulier le cas de la biscuiterie des
fromages et du pain cette situation
était absurde pour deux types de raison
s'agissant des fromages
on sait que globalement il y à ce
produit de manière traditionnelle et
ceux résultant de processus
industrialisés or les premiers temps
issus de la première transformation du
lait leur contenu nutritionnel ne peut
pas être modifiée dès lors leur a posé
des seuils très strictes en matières
grasses et en scène leur interdirait
d'alléguer sur leur apport en calcium
alors que n'importe quel soda ou jus de
fruits enrichi en calcium pourrait lui
de son côté vanté cet apport
nutritionnel ce qui concerne la
biscuiterie
le problème est différente il est
naturellement possible à l'industrie
agroalimentaire de réduire les teneurs
en sel en sucre ou en matières grasses
mais si on fixe des seuils trop strict
ces industriels n'auront donc à
l'intérêt économique à investir dans la
recherche développement
car leur retour sur investissement sera
beaucoup trop lointain est aléatoire
s'ils ne peuvent pas rapidement
communiquer sur leurs efforts en la
matière
donc on le voit il y avait dans ce
dossier un problème de proportionnalité
par rapport aux objectifs poursuivis par
le règlement de 2006 cette situation a
ému les professionnels notamment ceux du
secteur laitier qui m'ont alerté en
début d'année c'est ce qui a conduit à
l'adoption par la commission des
affaires européennes d'abord par celle
des affaires économiques ensuite de la
résolution numéro 83 qui vous a été
distribué cette résolution telle
qu'adoptée par votre commission des
affaires économiques demandent
essentiellement deux choses au
gouvernement d'abord une méthode vous
savez que depuis la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008
les assemblées françaises peuvent
adopter des résolutions européenne
surtout documents émanant d'une
institution européenne et non plus
uniquement sur les seuls projet
formalisé de directives ou de règlements
transmis au conseil et au parlement
européen cette extension est une
anticipation du traité de lisbonne
et c'est sur elle que je me suis appuyé
pour faire intervenir le sénat puisque
le texte en cause n'est qu'un document
de travail de la commission européenne
est pas un véritable projet de règlement
le problème c'est que la commission
produit quotidiennement des dizaines de
ces documents est qu'il est
matériellement impossible parlement
français d'avoir connaissance de
l'intégralité de cette production
si la plupart d'entre eux sont
essentiellement technique et ne
justifient pas d'intervention certains
cependant est l'exemple qui nous
préoccupe en est le témoignage ont
également un caractère politique
affirmée il est donc nécessaire que le
gouvernement transmette aux assemblées
les projets de mesures portant sur des
sujets présentant un intérêt politique
fait la première demande donc je me
répète problème de méthode
la seconde porte précisément sur le cas
d'espèce et demande au gouvernement de
se poser à l'adoption de seuil de
nutriments qui serait inadapté pour
certains
roduit dans cette perspective la
résolution formule 3 demande d'abord
pour ce qui concerne les profils
nutritionnels l'opposition à des seuils
de nutriments inadapté pour certaines
denrées ou qui favoriserait la
communication des produits standardisés
issus de l'industrie agroalimentaire
il vaut mieux manger un peu de fromage
un peu de légumes et des fruits que
d'assurer ses apports quotidiens en
calcium en fer et en vitamines par la
consommation de soldats enrichi de soda
enrichi par ces nutriments que
généralement il convient qu'en matière
de problématiques alimentaire les
représentants français à bruxelles fasse
valoir chaque fois que nécessaire
la nécessité de les examiner dans une
perspective globale et de respecter la
diversité des traditions alimentaires
propres à chaque état membre ce point
très important car il ne doit pas être
question que la commission sous couvert
de préoccupations sanitaires en viennent
à imposer un modèle alimentaire unique
qui plus est si ce modèle était
anglo-saxon
j'ai consacré du reste une partie de mon
rapport à faire état d'études
scientifiques qui tendent à démontrer
que ce modèle est en réalité beau
probablement beaucoup moins efficace
pour lutter contre le surpoids l'obésité
que le modèle latin représentait en
particulier par les habitudes françaises
donc notre position n'est pas seulement
culturel mais aussi sanitaires ainsi que
le relève plusieurs des considérants de
la proposition
enfin la dernière demande et de principe
les pouvoirs d'exécution conférer à la
commission européenne qu'il ne s'agit
pas de remettre en cause puisqu'ils sont
indispensables doivent cependant
toujours respecté les principes de
proportionnalité et de subsidiarité
principes auxquels la commission des
affaires européennes du sénat et tout
particulièrement attentive ainsi
qu'évidemment les objectifs des textes
communautaires qu'il s'agit de rendre
applicable dans le cas qui nous
préoccupe et les profils ne sont pas un
instrument de santé publique mais
simplement un outil
techniques destinées à garantir que
l'information commerciale destinée aux
consommateurs en matière nutritionnelle
et noyal c'est uniquement cet objectif
que le règlement d'application doit
s'attacher à satisfaire et pas un autre
depuis l'adoption de cette proposition
de résolution par la commission des
affaires économiques
cependant il semble que les choses ont
considérablement évolué et apparemment
dans le bon sens heureusement aussi
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais que
vous puissiez en quelques mots nous
faire le point sur l'état de ce dossier
d'abord nous informant précisément sur
les démarches du gouvernement français
avant et après l'adoption de la
résolution
ensuite et surtout en nous indiquant
qu'il est aujourd'hui l'état d'esprit de
la commission est ce qu'on doit attendre
de ces décisions à venir
il est bien évident de gel les dites
déjà au cours de cette intervention il y
as derrière tout cela un certain nombre
d'industriels qui sont engagés dans la
recherche développement et ils doivent
savoir quels objectifs ils doivent
donner à leur politique industrielle
pour précisément créent les richesses
qui sont précisément leur mission sur le
ministre le sénat peut-il avoir le
légitime espoir d'être aussi bien
entendu sur ce dossier qui l'a été sur
celui des vins rosés dont je me félicite
je vous remercie
merci monsieur lui c'est maintenant la
parole est un monsieur luc chatel
secrétaire d'état chargé de l'industrie
et de la consommation
présidence a rappelé m
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean bizet monsieur le
président de la commission votre
question traduit une préoccupation
majeure qui permet de démontrer à ceux
qui en doutaient encore que les choix
européens impacte directement la vie
quotidienne des consommateurs et la
réglementation européenne sur les
profils nutritionnels qui est
actuellement en discussion et bien
s'inscrit dans une volonté de poursuivre
des objectifs de santé publique et de
protection des consommateurs que chacun
seul sénateur peut naturellement à
priori partager la réglementation par
d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre de
constats de bon sens il est vrai qu'il
peut paraître choquant de voir des
produits se flatter d'être riche en
calcium avec des formulations type le
calcium contribuer à la croissance
osseuse
quand dans le même temps le produit
contient une forte proportion de
substance grasse sucrée ou salée pour le
dire simplement la réglementation vise à
éviter que n'importe quel produit puisse
dire je suis bon pour la santé
outre ces enjeux de nutrition la
commission souhaite défendre un autre
objectif que je crois nous partageons
tous à savoir la loyauté de
l'information c'est une condition du bon
exercice de la concurrence et pour que
celle ci ne soit pas faussée il faut
éviter que des industriels puissent
faire valoir aux yeux des consommateurs
un avantage compétitif qui n'a pas lieu
d'être
alors une fois ces principes posés
monsieur le sénateur bizet il reste la
question de leur déclinaison concrète
dans la législation et c'est
indiscutablement là que le bât blesse
nous savons que l'enfer est souvent pavé
de bonnes intentions
il ne faudrait pas que la défense
d'objectifs qui nous sont chères
viennent en contradiction totale avec
d'autres principes tout aussi important
à savoir la diversification de
l'alimentation du consommateur la
protection de nos produits traditionnels
comme le fromage ou les produits
céréaliers par exemple et la
compétitivité notre filière agricole et
agroalimentaire c'est pour cela monsieur
le sénateur que la france s'est opposée
à la première mouture de la
réglementation européenne
nous sommes encore dans une première
phase de consultation des pays membres
beaucoup partagent les positions de la
france et je peux vous rassurer tout de
suite mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en vous garantissant que le
nouveau projet de la commission sera
très éloigné du premier étreint et
tiendra compte des positions que nous
avons que je me permets de dire vous
avez défendu alors pourquoi la france
at-elle manifesté son désaccord et bien
l'objectif affiché par la réglementation
européenne est de restreindre le nombre
d'aliments pouvant porter des
allégations nutritionnelles en fonction
de leur composition leur
caractéristiques nutritionnelles global
mais le premier projet de la commission
paraissait extrêmement sévère puisqu'il
conduisait à une éligibilité moyenne aux
allégations de 41 % de produits
seulement avec des écarts allant de 2 à
80 1% selon les catégories de produits
par ailleurs la démarche de la
commission soulève un certain nombre de
questions
on peut d'abord observer que
l'établissement de critères objectifs de
sélection peut relever de la gageure
cela reviendrait à faire un tri entre
les bons et les mauvais aliments travail
difficiles voire 20 quand on sait que
les autorités scientifiques martèle
qu'il n'y a pas de bon ou de mauvais
aliments mais seulement des combinaison
d'aliments permettant de créer ou non un
équilibre alimentaire
une autre limite évidente réside dans le
fait que pour certains produits
agricoles traditionnelles peu ou pas
transformer les marges de manoeuvre en
matière de reformulation s'avère
extrêmement réduites alors même que ces
produits constituent la base de notre
aide
mentation ses limites évidentes doivent
nous amener à être extrêmement vigilants
sur le niveau de sévérité du dispositif
que nous devons adopter
cela est d'ailleurs reconnue dans les
exposés du règlement qui rappelle ainsi
je cite ce que les profils devrait
prendre en compte les habitudes et les
traditions alimentaires ainsi que le
fait que des produits considérés
individuellement peuvent jouer un rôle
important dans le cadre d'un régime
alimentaire globale mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous avez eu
raison de souligner les risques corps
est une transposition trop rigoureuse ou
trop restrictive du texte européen les
points et les critiques que vous avez
relevé monsieur sénateurs bizet
rejoignent parfaitement la position
défendue par michel barnier au nom de la
france que je tiens d'ailleurs à excuser
puisque il est aujourd'hui à bruxelles
et que il m'a chargé de le représenter
devant votre assemblée vous demander au
gouvernement dans le cadre des
discussions communautaires sur les
profils de s'opposer à de nouvelles
propositions de seuil de nutriments qui
serait inadapté pour certaines denrées
ou qui tendrait à promouvoir la
consommation des seuls produits
standardisés issus de l'industrie
agroalimentaire
eh bien c'est ce que nous faisons vous
nous avez également invités à examiner
la question des profils dans une
perspective d' équilibre alimentaire
globale là encore vous êtes parfaitement
en ligne avec la position que le
gouvernement fait valoir auprès de la
commission la position française repose
en effet sur quatre considération
importante
la première considération c'est la prise
en compte des caractéristiques
nutritionnelles global de l'aliment et
pas seulement les aspects négatifs
la direction générale de la santé la
protection des consommateurs de la
commission proposait un système de
contrôle reposant sur trois nutriments
acides gras saturés sucre et sel
les autorités françaises ont accepté ce
choix qu'elle mérite de la simplicité
en revanche la france a soutenu la mise
en perspective de l'aliment dans le
régime alimentaire globale il s'agit en
effet de distinguer pour chaque produit
les apports en nutriments négatif mais
aussi positif dans le cadre d'un régime
alimentaire globale ainsi il est vrai
que les fromages sont riches en acides
gras saturés mais force est de constater
que la majorité des consommateurs ne
mange pas du fromage à chaque repas ni
tous les jours et avec une consommation
de 30 grammes par jour en moyenne
le fromage n'est donc pas un
contributeur majeur à l'apport total
d'acides gras saturés
en revanche le fromage apporte une
contribution majeure à l'apport
calciques plus de 50% du calcium
consommer quotidiennement est apportée
par les produits laitiers dont plus de
20% par les fromages et ce qui est vrai
pour le fromage ne l'est pas forcément
pour tous les produits
ainsi la demande des chocolatiers de
création d'une catégorie pour leurs
produits et de seuils adapté à elle été
rejetée
ces produits n'étant pas des
contributeurs majeurs en nutriments
essentiels la deuxième considération que
porte le gouvernement c'est une plus
grande proportionnalité que vous avez
évoqué monsieur le sénateur l'autorité
européenne de sécurité des aliments a
identifié les catégories d'aliments
ayant une place importante dans le
régime alimentaire des seuils adapté ont
été proposés pour ces catégories
mais la définition des catégories et
parfois contestables ainsi les biscuits
et les produits de panification ont été
associés aux féculents comme les pâtes
ou de riz
cela les a fortement pénalisé dans les
différentes propositions de la
commission puisque 7 et 14 %
d'éligibilité pour les biscuits et le
pain contre 80% pour le riz et 92 % pour
les patrons été évoquée eh bien la
france a souhaité garantir une meilleure
proportionnalité il s'agit d'améliorer
la définition des catégories et de
réhausser certains
y est particulièrement pénalisant il
faut aussi tenir compte de la situation
de produits diététiques dans la
composition vise à répondre à des
besoins de multi sionnel particulier par
exemple pour les nourrissons ou pour les
sportifs s'agissant de ces produits
spécifiques le gouvernement a soutenu
l'idée qu'il soit exonéré des profils
dès lors que le besoin nutritionnel
particulier impose un déplacement des
profils ainsi un produit pour sportifs
ne seraient pas soumis au teneur
maximale en sucre ou en sodium
dès lors que les toners apportées sont
justifiées par les besoins nutritionnels
des sportifs en revanche des apports
élevés en acides gras saturés élevé
n'étant pas justifié
chez les sportifs les produits seraient
soumis au profil pour ce nutriment
troisième considération que défend le
gouvernement c'est l'incitation à la
reformulation le plan national nutrition
santé par le biais des chartes
d'engagement a engagé une démarche
partenariale entre l'état les opérateurs
afin d'inciter ceux ci à améliorer la
qualité nutritionnelle de leurs produits
il paraissait dès lors inconcevable de
défendre des seuils interdisant l'accès
à toute forme de communication sur la
qualité nutritionnelle des produits et
ce quels que soient les efforts et
progrès réalisés et également à
concevable de supprimer toute incitation
à la reformulation enfin dernière
considération monsieur le sénateur que
nous défendons et qui sous tend notre
position c'est la cohérence avec la
politique nutritionnelle et avec la
culture alimentaire française en droite
ligne avec sa politique nutritionnelle
et alimentaire la position française a
mis en valeur la nécessaire
diversification des aliments au sein du
régime
l'exemple type est la communication que
nous faisons en france sur trois
produits laitiers différents par jour y
compris par les fromages quand la
commission elle prônait une satisfaction
des besoins en calcium
par le sol et où les yaourts en outre la
position française a été établi au
regard de considération que nous
partageons tous je crois et qui sont
plus culturels tels que la défense des
produits traditionnels et des produits
agricoles
ceci constitue la base de l'alimentation
française et reste des repères
structurants dans le régime et les
habitudes alimentaires
leur marge de manoeuvre en matière de
reformulation est évidemment faible le
gouvernement a donc considéré qu'il
était plus pertinent de valoriser le
calcium apportées par les fromages que
celui ajouté artificiellement au soda
comme vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
sénateur la même façon les autorités
françaises ont défendu ardemment que les
produits bruts non transformés comme les
viandes ou les poissons soit exonéré de
l'application des profils mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bizet comme vous pouvez le
constater la france le gouvernement a
adopté une position à la fois
proportionnée respectueuse de la
tradition culinaire française et
soucieuse des intérêts des consommateurs
en matière de nutrition
cette position rejoint donc très
clairement les positions que vous avez
exprimées monsieur bizet au nom du sénat
à travers votre résolution et monsieur
le ministre
alors nous allons engager la procédure
de discussion interactive et spontané
qui souhaitent intervenir
monsieur le calame et l'eau la seul
président c'est le ministre chers
collègues mon questionnement porte sur
ce que pourrait envisager le
gouvernement afin de contrecarrer cette
tendance de standardisation des aliments
et de diététique à sion de
l'alimentation qui ne correspondent pas
à la culture française
étroitement liée au problème croissant
d'obésité qui frappe d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus les pays qui promotionne ce type de
directive
le gouvernement pourrait lancer en
france un plan sans précédent auprès des
jeunes des familles de toutes les
structures d'éducation et des filières
de transformation et de communication un
plan destiné à allier la qualité la
connaissance l'hygiène de vie le sport
et le plaisir de la table car l'esprit
de rabelais n'est pas mort fort
heureusement nous ne partons pas de rien
certes mais je pense que nous pourrions
faire beaucoup plus compte tenu des
enjeux notamment ceux de l'obésité et du
surpoids qui nous menace à terme comme
les autres pays merci merci madame mélo
mais ensuite il monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ce débat illustre une fois de plus la
nécessité pour l'union européenne de
faire de la politique dans la façon de
traiter certains sujets comme les
profils nutritionnels ou le vin rosé
faire de la politique c'est peut-être
avant tout avoir du bon sens afin de
mesurer la dimension politique de toute
décision
le projet de réglementation des profils
nutritionnels part d'une bonne idée mais
les seuils sont fixés un tel niveau
qu'en réalité la plus grande partie des
fromages français se trouve en quelque
sorte disqualifié un comble pour nos
fromages au lait cru et nous a aussi du
saint nectaire aux comptes et en passant
par le neuchâtel sans oublier la fourme
d'ambert
le sainte maure de touraine ou le brie
de meaux et bien sûr le brie de melun
que je défends en particulier en tant
qu'élu de melun tous ces produits du
terroir qui appartiennent au patrimoine
straw nomique de notre pays non
seulement n'ont jamais tué personne mais
grâce à leur richesse en calcium ou en
ferment lactique ont permis à des
millions d'enfants au fil des siècles de
se développer et de fortifier leur masse
osseuse un capital santé
sans la vigilance de la commission des
affaires européennes du sénat et de sa
commission des affaires économiques et
sans le sérieux de notre collègue jean
bizet ce projet aurait été adoptée en
catimini par un comité d'experts et par
la commission européenne
alors que ce texte pénalise non
seulement les productions
traditionnelles françaises
mais l'ensemble du modèle français
d'alimentation et de gastronomie
nous savons tous que la santé repose
d'abord sur une alimentation équilibrée
et non sur des seuils arbitraires et des
produits calibrés
gardons nous de tous qui uniformise et
aseptise notre alimentation
protégeons et encouragements au
contraire la diversité et la qualité
dont nos fromages du terroir sont le
meilleur exemple
monsieur le ministre il est impératif
que le gouvernement soit beaucoup plus
vigilants et plus réactif sur ce type de
dossier on peut en effet se demander
légitimement pourquoi le parlement et
plus particulièrement le sénat n'a pas
été mise au courant plus en amont
désormais c'est un débat qui concerne
tous les français qui sont en droit de
nous demander des comptes sur ce sujet
merci monsieur le ministre
bien monsieur le sénateur madame le
sénateur d'abord je voudrais rappeler
que l'esprit de l'intervention j'ai fait
tout à l'heure je crois répond à vos
interrogations sur la défense d'un
modèle de nutrition et de filières
agroalimentaires que je crois nous
partageons tous au delà des différentes
sensibilités de votre assemblée et je
crois que le gouvernement a démontré à
la fois à travers sa position sur cette
proposition de la commission mais aussi
sur un certain nombre d'initiatives
qu'il préservait qu'il souhaitait
maintenir cette diversité qui favorise
aussi le développement économique de nos
terroirs avec la spécificité
agroalimentaire je voudrais rappeler
quelques initiatives qui ont été prises
par le gouvernement en la matière et par
michel barnier
je pense au plan d'action qui découlent
du pnns et qui prend en compte la
nécessité avec da proches alimentaire
liée à notre culture est liée à nos
terroirs nous avons clairement voulu
l'inscrire dans ce plan national je
prends aussi comme exemple à l'action
que nous avons menée vis-à-vis de nos
amis américains sur le roquefort par
exemple pour défendre un label et une
identité donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement a démontré sur sa très
longue de mesure et sa position en
réponse à la question de monsieur bizet
face aux propositions initiales de la
commission
même le sénateur vous m'interrogez aussi
sur la forme savoir pourquoi vous n'avez
pas été associés plus en amont je
rappelle que d'abord à ce jour il n'y a
aucune proposition officielle de la
commission et que jusqu'à présent le
débat est resté à un niveau technique
simplement nos services ont alerté le
gouvernement sur les préoccupations et
les inquiétudes qui pourrait traduire la
mise en oeuvre de la proposition
initiale de la commission
nous sommes donc mobilisés à partir des
premières orientations de la commission
et c'est sur la base de cette
mobilisation que le président barroso a
modifier la proposition initiale de la
commission et a demandé à sa direction
de repenser et de faire de nouvelles
propositions
ces propositions à ce jour restent
encore non officielle et donc le
gouvernement travaille avec ses services
pour orienter la position européenne
dans l'esprit de ce que j'ai évoqué tout
à l'heure et conformément d'ailleurs aux
préconisations et aux remarques du
sénateur bizet donc nous aurons à être
extrêmement vigilants dans les mois qui
viennent dans les semaines qui viennent
plus exactement pour que les
propositions finales de la commission
prenne bien en compte la réorientation
voulue par monsieur barroso et surtout
les préconisations que j'ai défendue
tout à l'heure dans mon intervention
monsieur visez vous souhaitez réaliser
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je voudrais me réjouir que
suite aux informations de monsieur le
ministre le nouveau projet de la
commission soit très éloignées
précisément de la première version en
quelque sorte et je remercie le
gouvernement d'avoir entendu l'appel du
parlement sur ce point précis et je
voudrais me réjouir également à mettre
cela en exergue devant le président de
la commission des affaires européennes
que la modification de la constitution
de juillet 2008
eh bien nous est permis et nous permette
à l'avenir d'être beaucoup plus réactif
sur le sujet parce qu'il permet
d'anticiper le traité de lisbonne
réactivité du parlement mise en va en
avant en quelque sorte de ce qu'on
appelle la proportionnalité et la
subsidiarité
c'est ainsi à mon avis qu'on pourra
mieux faire accepter par nos concitoyens
la dimension et l'action de l'europe
dans leur quotidien je voudrais
également souligner l'importance de
créer de plus en plus dans ce sens le
plus noble du terme
des passerelles entre le monde de
l'entreprise et le parlement parce que
si précisément la filière ou plus
justement la transformation laitière ne
m'avait pas alerter c'est quelque chose
qui nous aurait littéralement échappe t
et quand on voit les turbulences que vit
aujourd'hui la filière lait
hier on devine si vous voulez que la
communication sur l'ensemble des
produits la filière laitière les
produits de transformation
si un tel dossier avait suivi j'dirais
son cheminement législatif dans quel
état les transformateurs se seraient
trouvés et en amont les producteurs les
producteurs de lait donc au travers de
cette discussion et j'espère au delà de
cet hémicycle que les créateurs de
richesse que sont les chefs
d'entreprises comprennent bien que le
parlement est très à l'écouté de leurs
préoccupations
on ne peut pas formalisé bien évidemment
ces passerelles entre entre le parlement
et le monde de l'entreprise simplement
qu'ils sachent que nous sommes très
attentifs à leurs soucis du quotidien et
que c'est ainsi que l'on doit désormais
à mon avis fonctionner et encore une
fois je souhaite véritablement que le
traité de lisbonne puisse être dans les
mois qui viennent une réalité pour
permettre d'être très efficace dans je
dirais le quotidien tant nouveau de nos
entreprises que nos consommateurs
merci merci pas d'autres demandes de
parole donc la filière laitière viendra
le 25 juin
alors nous allons passer au débat sur le
vin rosé
la parole ne vous surprendra pas à
l'aide à notre collègue gérard césar au
nom de la commission des affaires
économiques sur wii qui s'occupait du
bordeaux même du rosé
tous les vélos
il est là il est prêt monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
une fois n'est pas coutume nous sommes
aujourd'hui réunis non pour critiquer
l'action des instances communautaires
natalie cole mais pour nous féliciter de
son absence d'action définitive je
laisse faire
le projet de la commission européenne
d'autoriser le coupage pour la
production du vin rosé de table et
finalement abandonnée pour combien de
temps c'est la question qu'on peut se
poser
il est vrai qu'on peut voir le verre si
j'ose dire moitié plein ou à moitié vide
dans le premier cas on se réjouit que
nos producteurs puissent produire et
continuer à produire des vins
d'excellence qui ne sont pas en
concurrence est déloyale mans par des
productions venant des pays tiers mais
le verre est à moitié vide
carrefour aussi révèle une fois de plus
le degré d'incompréhension par la
commission des réalités et des enjeux
agricoles et viticoles dans les états
membres
si on se souvient bien le combat a
autant dire le mot était pourtant mal
engagée fin janvier quand le comité de
gestion des verts qui réunit des experts
des 27 états membres votent à titre
indicatif le projet de règlement sur les
pratiques oenologiques au sein de
l'union
aucun des participants france y compris
n'y voit rien à redire
pourtant figure de ce texte
d'application de la grande réforme gros
cm viticole votée en 2007 la lever
l'interdiction de produire des rosé de
table par coupage pour le commissaire
européen à l'agriculture le coupage est
censé permettre aux producteurs
européens de jouer à armes égales face à
leurs concurrents américains australiens
au sud africaine qui peuvent
commercialiser mélange rouge et blanc
sous le nom de rosée sur le territoire
communautaire
une fois prise la mesure de la réforme
la résistance entre guillemets
s'organise
notre ministre de culture mais ce michel
barnier s'alarme ce projet auprès de
madame fischer boel commissaire
européenne
1co premier concocté de 23,9 au sein du
comité de gestion du verre y est
entériné la possibilité pour le vin rosé
authentique c'est à dire obtenues par
des méthodes traditionnelles de
vinification et non par coupage puissent
bénéficier de l'appellation vin
traditionnel mentionner sur l'étiquette
or le professionnel on le sait ne
veulent pas cette mesure
le vin est un produit jeunes le vin rosé
est un produit jeunes apprécié par les
femmes
mesdames et par les jeunes aussi mais je
mets les femmes en priorité parce que ce
sont des connaisseurs et c'est elle qui
vont avec un grand magasin acheter ce
produit magnifique
et oui comme d'habitude président et le
et la mention traditionnel risques et de
leur donner un aspect poussiéreux
l'opposition au projet de la commission
est donc reconduite mais je partage et
le partage des forces jouent pam à notre
faveur la france est alors isolé et ne
dispose pas véritablement d'appui pour
bloquer la mesure dont l'adoption est
renvoyé au conseil des ministres la
culture du 19 juin 2009 c'est à ce
moment que notre assemblée se saisit du
dossier
avec mon collègue simon sutour en tant
que président du groupe d'études vigne
et vin de dépose auprès de la commission
européenne présidée par monsieur hubert
haenel une proposition de résolution
invitant le gouvernement à se poser à
disposition permettant d'obtenir du vin
rosé par coupage de vin rouge de vin
blanc chargé par la commission des
affaires économiques et un accord avec
mon collègue roland courteau auprès de
laquelle le texte était envahie et
renvoyés de leur apporter je procède à
une série d'auditions des principaux
acteurs de la filière
le rapport est la proposition soit
adoptée à l'unanimité
c'est important de le préciser par notre
commission le 3 mai dernier le texte
devenu résolution du sénat dix jours
plus tard invité le gouvernement à
s'opposer fermement à la suppression de
l'interdiction de coupe
les vins sans indication géographique de
couleurs différentes pour produire des
vins tranquilles rosé parallèlement les
viticulteurs s'organisent et si que nous
préconisions notre rapport mène des
actions importantes communication à ce
sujet auprès du grand public et de leurs
collègues des attentes des autres états
membres concernés le 26 mai ils
organisent une conférence de presse à
bruxelles à laquelle les producteurs
italiens espagnols s'associe la campagne
rouge et rosé coupé n'est pas rosé est
lancée les façon très efficace
la pétition contre le rosé coupé
circulant sur internet
recueil plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de signatures récent sondage montre que
87 % de nos compatriotes sont opposés à
l'autorisation de coupage et que 86 % ne
l'achèterai jamais si un tel vin venait
à être commercialisés sont mis en avant
les qualités et leur unité du vin rosé
authentique ainsi que l'importance
économique du secteur ni vin blanc ni
vert rouge ni mélange des deux le vin
rosé traditionnel est en effet un verra
pas et à part de ceux par ses
spécificités de couleurs de textures de
goût et de conservation
le marché du rouge vin rosé se porte
bien surtout dans notre pays la france
est le leader mondial du secteur mais
30% de la production européenne qui
provient principalement de la province
de la loire du rhône du sud une autre
france et enfin vous permettrez de dire
qui vient aussi de la gironde il
constitue en constante de notre vignoble
génère 1 milliard d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et occupe directement en 2000
personnes et 66 mille emplois induits la
demande vers rosé ne cesse d'augmenter
ils représentent 24 % de la consommation
française totale du vin contre 11% en 90
soit plus que le vin blanc désormais
plusieurs explications explique cet
engouement pour le vin rosé
des caractéristiques qui correspondent
bien aux attentes du public
le plus grand de facilité d'accès pour
des consommateurs peu expérimenté en
matière de vin ou encore il faut bien le
souligner les efforts remarquables
réalisés par la filière pour rendre le
produit plus attractif que ce soit en
termes de qualité de prix ou de
marketing
si ces éléments de vercel emporté la
conviction la présentation des risques
du coupage figurent dans le rapport
enfoncer le clou le vin rosé issu de
coupage présente en effet d'importants
inconvénients
d'abord un risque de santé utilisation
et quand on sait que l'introduction d'un
volume elles fument 1% ou même 2 % de
vins rouges et vins blancs suffit il
donnait l'apparence mais rien que
l'apparence d'un vrai rosé
on imagine aussi ce que certains
auraient tenté de faire colorer des
quantités industrielles de vin blanc de
mauvaise qualité pour obtenir du vin
rosie la formidable palette de goûts et
de couleurs des rosés traditionnels rue
alors été perdus au profit d'un produit
interchangeables deuxième risque que les
déclarations l'absence de les verts osé
couper des molécules donnant aux vins sa
rondeur peut être compensée par une
macération plus longue
source d'une certaine rugosité enfin
dernier rist nous allons finalement
éviter la confusion pour le consommateur
ce ministre celui ci aurait été amené à
acheter un vin ya un aspect chromatique
10 et spécialiste du rosé mais
absolument pas le goût on imagine qu'ils
n'auraient pas été incités à racheter
pour toutes ces raisons il fallait nous
opposer avec clarté fermeté au projet la
commission c'est ce que nous avons fait
en étroite liaison entre le ministre et
le sénat nos arguments ont porté puisque
notre parc pays est parvenu au finish
mais en montant au filet retourner
suffisamment de partenaires potentiels
pour s'assurer une minorité de blocage
qui comme le président d'une aile le
souligner est égal à 91 voix italie
roumanie hongrie autriche allemagne et
d'autres pays nouveaux adhérents de
l'europe nous ont soutenus
cette configuration du rapport des
forces alliées peut-être à survenance
des élections européennes
peut-être sait-on jamais su que la
décision était intervenue quelques jours
après les élections européennes
nous n'oublions pas de le souligner a
donc finalement entraîné le recul de la
commission à la grande satisfaction de
nos professionnels
dès lors les questions que je souhaitais
poser représentants du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre lors du présent
débat nous sommes peut-être plus
d'activités pour le moment soyons
prudents une scène interrogations
demeurent peut-être l'organisation
mondiale du commerce à laquelle le
dossier avait été renvoyé pour avis est
ce que l'om c'est à examiner justement
ce dossier qu'est-ce que tu en auto
terme de se voir reprocher à
l'interdiction de coupage
non pas tant les sens communautaire et
par celle de mc pour entrave à la libre
concurrence
vous achèteriez monsieur le ministre de
nous rassurer en nous apportant des
éléments sur ce point tout en rappelant
ce qu'a fait un commissaire européen un
nouveau commissaire peut le défaire ne
faudrait il pas monsieur le ministre et
monsieur le président l invité monsieur
lamy directeur de raismes c'est à venir
s'exprimer sur tous les points en
discussion même si aujourd'hui en
particulier sur la question qui était
posée par notre collègue jean bizet sur
les produits nutritionnels mais aussi
sur le vin rosé et peut-être d'autres
points merci monsieur président donc il
faut que nous soyons vigilants sur tous
les fronts je conclurai en me
réjouissant à nouveau du retrait de ce
projet inacceptable pour une filière des
qualités comme l'est celle du vin rosé
français et me félicite en effet positif
nos travaux sur le dénouement de ce
dossier
preuve s'il en était besoin que l'union
du parlement de l'exécutif des acteurs
économiques nationaux en france et à
bruxelles permet d'obtenir sa direction
lorsque la cause juste défendu avec aux
missions telles que le mariage
aujourd'hui des fromages et du rosé
personne ne doute de votre conviction
chers collègues bien la parole est à luc
chatel secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'industrie la consommation sur cet
important dossier
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gérard césar
le président de la commission doit à
nouveau excusé michel barnier qui a été
un acteur majeur dans ce dossier sujet
du vin rosé qui a été au coeur des
débats de débat politique et médiatique
passionnés ces dernières semaines et
pour cause monsieur césar et vous l'avez
très bien dit dès que des discussions
européennes portent sur des sujets aussi
sensibles qui touchent à notre
patrimoine gustatif oenologique à notre
culture
disons le aussi un secteur économique
important
eh bien il est naturel que les
professionnels comme le grand public
a fortiori la représentation nationale
demande une attention toute particulière
de la part du gouvernement
au delà de la sensibilité naturelle du
sujet qui est un véritable symbole eh
bien ce peut-être que certains auraient
heureux de faire du vin rosé le symbole
d'une europe éloigné technocratique
sourde à nos préoccupations et à la
défense des patrimoines nationaux
eh bien je crois que ce sujet montre
comme bien d'autres que l'europe quand
on le veut n'est pas une machine froide
sur laquelle nous n'avons pas d'emprise
l'europe ce n'est pas eux l'europe c'est
nous et donc l'enseignement de ce
dossier c'est que pour obtenir des
orientations et des décisions favorables
il nous faut peser faire valoir notre
point de vue de manière déterminée et
volontariste et l'initiative que vous
avez prises monsieur gérard césar est
tout à fait emblématique en la matière
alors à l'occasion du vote indicatif
préalable à la consultation de l'om sait
le 27 janvier dernier la france avait
fait part de ses vives réserves sur la
levée de l'interdiction du coupage tout
en se prononçant d'ailleurs
favorablement sur le reste du texte
compte tenu des réponses positives
apportées à ses autres demandes et j'y
reviendrai la france était initialement
très isolé sur la question puisque seule
la hongrie la soutenait elle a obtenu le
report du vin des deux règlements en
débat les pratiques oenologiques et les
règles d'étiquetage à la fin du mois de
juin et elle a donc mis à profit ce
délai pour expliquer sa position aux
autres états membres et rechercher des
soutiens
michel barnier a ainsi écrit à la
commissaire le 11 février et le 13 mars
et il a porté ce sujet mal connu à
plusieurs reprises à l'attention de ses
homologues à l'occasion des conseils des
ministres de l'agriculture
la commission a indiqué qu'elle
n'entendait pas modifier le règlement
sur les pratiques oenologiques et a
proposé de manière alternative de donner
la possibilité aux états membres de
distinguer le rosé traditionnel et le
rosé de coupage sur l'étiquetage la
france s'est abstenue sur ce projet en
rappelant sa ferme opposition à la levée
de l'interdiction du coupage des vins
rouges et blancs sans indication
géographique
en effet cette solution ne garantissait
pas un régime commun entre états membres
et ne s'applique qu'aux 20 de l'état
membre qui le décide
les professionnels ont enfin insisté à
plusieurs reprises sur le décalage entre
l'appellation rosé traditionnel qui leur
est proposé et l'image moderne qui leur
est associé
devant la mobilisation des gouvernements
français puis italien les
professionnelles et des professionnels
la commission a indiqué le 8 juin
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur césar
qu'il n'y aura pas de changement dans
les règles de production du vin rosé sur
la question des pratiques oenologiques
relatives à l'élaboration du vin rosé
le gouvernement a donc travaillé en lien
étroit avec la
mission les professionnels et les autres
états membres dès cet automne et la
décision de la commission de renoncer au
coupage montre que cette méthode de la
concertation était la bonne elle
constitue la victoire d'un certain
modèle alimentaire que nous avons évoqué
dans le débat précédent respectant les
droits des consommateurs
les savoir faire des producteurs et les
traditions qui nous sont chères c'était
un combat important et urgent parce que
le règlement actuel qui interdit le
coupage et bien prenait fin au 1er août
ceux qui ont dénoncé l'attitude ouverte
de dialogue du gouvernement avec la
commission et les autres états doivent
comprendre que cette proposition
s'inscrit par ailleurs dans une réforme
plus large qui est celle de
l'organisation commune de marché
vitivinicole dont un enjeu majeur et de
renforcer la compétitivité de cette
filière de toute la filière du vin c'est
ainsi que la prop la commission a
proposé de lever plusieurs restrictions
telles que la désalcoolisation ou
l'utilisation de copies de copeaux qui
est attendu par la profession et
l'économie globale de cette réforme elle
est bonne pour la profession elle est
essentielle pour cette filière qui dans
un contexte de réduction de la
consommation nationale doit
impérativement reconquérir des parts de
marché à l'exportation
concernant la question spécifique de la
levée de l'interdiction de mélange de
vin rouge et de vin blanc sans
indication géographique pour produire du
vin rosé
michel barnier a entendu les producteurs
qui lui ont fait part le 14 janvier 2009
de leur opposition à la proposition de
la commission parce qu'elle risquait de
changer la donne cette proposition était
en effet de nature à remettre en cause
l'équilibré économique de la filière des
vins rosés français de qualité qui a
mené depuis de nombreuses années une
politique d'amélioration de sa qualité
dans le respect des modes de fabrication
traditionnelle et le gouvernement est
conscient à la fois les efforts réalisés
et des enjeux et
économiques qui sont en cause dans ce
dossier puisque la france est le premier
producteur mondial de vin rosé avec 29 %
la production mondiale lequel représente
aujourd'hui près de 9% de la
consommation mondiale de vin en outre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs en
tant que secrétaire d'état à la
consommation
eh bien je crois que cela revêt une
importance particulière à mes yeux il
était primordial qu'il n'y ait pas d'
amalgame aux yeux du consommateur entre
deux types de produits intrinsèquement
différents enfin monsieur césar vous
interroger le gouvernement sur la
question de l' omc vous avez raison où
est examiné le dossier qui est
aujourd'hui revu par la commission et
n'a pas formulé de remarques relatives
aux questions des pratiques de
désalcoolisation et de coupage dans la
mesure où cette interdiction du coupage
qui a été donc rétabli lundi dernier par
la commission s'applique aux vins
produits au sein des états membres de
l'union européenne et ne produit donc en
conséquence pas d'obstacle au commerce
avec les pays tiers et bien l'om sait
n'a pas de motif de dénoncer cette
pratique au titre de l' entrave à la
libre concurrence
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires ce que je voulais
rappeler sur la position qui a été
défendu par le gouvernement et qui je
crois monsieur le sénateur césar a
répondu aux attentes que vous avez
exprimées dans votre résolution
il s'agit indiscutablement d'une
victoire que nous devons partager entre
le parlement les professionnels et le
gouvernement après plusieurs mois de
dialogue avec la commission et les
autres états membres n'est fait
secrétaire d'état donc maintenant nous
allons procéder à la discussion
interactive et spontanée je crois savoir
que notre collègue roland courteau brûle
de d'intervenir sur ses skis à d'autres
madame brügger monsieur courteau
voudrait la parole merci monsieur le
président
le bon sens et la raison vienne
semble-t-il de l'emporter si j'en crois
la récente décision de la commission
européenne de faire marche arrière en
renonçant à son projet d'autoriser le
mélange vin blanc vin rouge pour faire
du rosé renoncement définitif ou
provisoire
tel est encore la question nos
interventions et j'avais soutenu la
proposition de résolution de gérard
césar et de simon sutour en commission
des affaires économiques
nos interventions ajoutées à celles des
représentants de la profession ont
semble-t-il contribuer à corriger ce qui
fut plus qu'une erreur mais une faute
à l'origine de cette faute il faut
rappeler qu'en fait la commission
européenne avec l'aval des états membres
avaient dit vouloir je cite libérer
l'europe de ses entraves oenologiques
voilà qui est grave pour le présent et
l'avenir
en effet c'est ignorer que ce sont ces
mêmes règles logiques et l'interdiction
de faire n'importe quoi qui ont fait la
renommée des produits de qualité comme
les vins français
j'insiste pour dire que plutôt que
d'aligner certains de nos pratiques
d'ogic sur celles des pays du nouveau
monde
j'aurais préféré que l'union européenne
mette le paquet sur la promotion intra
et extra communautaire de nos produits
et sur la valorisation de l'authenticité
de mauvaises et leurs liens forts avec
les terroirs
si les états membres ne compte pas de
telles prises de positions
ultralibérales de la commission alors
nous allons droit vers un nivellement
qualitatif par le bas comment les états
membres ont-ils pu laisser passer dans
un premier temps une telle mesure
il s'agit d'une véritable hérésie digne
des pratiques d'alchimiste comment at-on
pu laisser passer ce qui n'aurait été
rien d'autre qu'une contrefaçon
alimentaire mais jusqu'où va-t-on aller
si l'afer n'étaient pas aussi graves on
pourrait aller jusqu'à cité l'humoriste
pierre dac qui suggérait de greffer des
rosiers sur les vignes pour produire du
vin rosé
comment donc nos instances européennes
ont elles pu prendre une telle
initiative sans aucune concertation avec
la profession et sans mesurer les
conséquences économiques désastreuses
pour les producteurs mais chez le
ministre
quand la france at-elle pu se laisser à
marquer en janvier dernier à bruxelles
dans cette aventure lors du comité de
réglementation puisque madame fischer
boel la commissaire a bien précisé que
la france avait voté pour la france à
l'avenir et c'est là ma question
monsieur le président fera t-elle preuve
de davantage de vigilance car comme l'a
dit monsieur le rapporteur ce qu'a fait
un commissaire européen
un autre commissaire européen peut le
refaire 6 alors après la gironde heulot
de maintenant les veaux avec madame
brugière le président sur les ministres
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs chers
collègues comme vous vous en doutez je
m'apprêtais à interpeller le
gouvernement sur la question du coupage
du vin blanc et du vin rouge pour
fabriquer du vin rosé qui était sur le
point d'être adoptée par la commission
européenne
c'est donc avec une grande satisfaction
que j'ai appris le lundi 8 juin
qu'est-ce qu'elle renon qu'elle y
renoncer inutile d'insister sur le tollé
que ce projet avait provoqué auprès des
producteurs de vin rosé des
professionnels de la filière des élus
concernés et aussi de la population qui
considérait ce projet comme dangereux
tant pour les professions viticole que
pour leur atteinte aux valeurs de nos
terroirs et de notre identité
selon un sondage ifop je reprendrai ce
qu'a dit notre collègue gérard tout à
l'heure
publiés dans le sud ouest et le midi
libre 87% des français y étaient ainsi
opposé nous savons que c'est grâce à ces
vins rosés élaboré selon un mode de
macération spécifique que la france
occupe la première place de producteur
mondial de vin rosé de qualité surtout
représentant quinze mille emplois
direct et 70 mille emplois indirects
dans l'hexagone grâce à une mobilisation
sans faille et l'implication admirable
de michel barnier ministre de
l'agriculture et de la pêche le dialogue
engagé depuis plusieurs mois avec
mariann fischer boel commissaire en
charge de l'agriculture et du
développement a porté ses fruits
et je m'en réjouis le sénat a aussi eu
une place de premier plan dans ce combat
avec la mobilisation des sénateurs
concernés et l'adoption de la résolution
européenne adopté par la commission des
affaires économiques sur le sujet
j'ajoute que les producteurs du
languedoc roussillon qui avait déployé
ces dernières années des efforts
constants en matière de qualité et de
saveur de leurs produits notamment eu
égard aux règles entourant les
appellations contrôlées sont
particulièrement soulagé du maintien de
l'interdiction du coupage qui dans le
cas contraire aurait été vécue comme une
profonde injustice
la décision de la commission européenne
est donc une excellente nouvelle
au lendemain des élections européennes
cela prouve aussi que l'europe sait
écouter et protéger le savoir faire des
vignerons
je reprendrai mon compte les propos du
ministre de l'agriculture italien la
tradition l'a emporté c'est de cette
europe que nous voulons celle qui fondée
sur le respect de l'identité de la
sécurité alimentaire et de la tradition
cependant la plus grande vigilance doit
rester de mise
à cet égard il me semble utile d'obtenir
des précisions sur le maintien de
l'interdiction du coupage
monsieur le ministre dispose de tonnes
de garantie sur le caractère total est
irrévocable cette interdiction
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que la
commission sera modifié à l'automne
prochain
il est donc utile de connaître les
raisons de fond qui ont motivé le
revirement de cette commission que
j'applaudis une nouvelle fois
ainsi que la perspicacité du
gouvernement et du parlement français
est comme mon collègue gérard césar
j'ajoute qu'il faut rester très vigilant
sur la négociation du volet agricole de
l'om sait je vous remercie
même si je vous souhaitez réagir mais là
encore monsieur le cam
monsieur le cam n'est pas d'un
département viticole mais c'est un grand
connaisseur du rosé c'est pas si le
président fait le mini chers collègues
notre groupe se réjouit du recul de la
commission sur le sujet du coupage du
vin rosé
il s'agit malheureusement d'une
exception tenu par l'immense
mobilisation d'un certain nombre de pays
du monde viticole et des parlementaires
dans leur ensemble nous avons
malheureusement l'habitude de percevoir
l'europe comme une grosse structure qui
ralentit ou s'arrête parfois mais ne
recule qu'exceptionnellement ma
sollicitations envers le gouvernement
concerne un point commun aux deux
directives que nous abordons ce matin
dans ce débat est malheureusement à la
majeure partie d'entre elles
l'aberration du vin rosé obtenu par
coupage de vin rouge et de vin blanc
illustrent à merveille ce qui se passe à
bruxelles sous la pression des lobbys
ici celui des pinardiers dont les
finalités peu philanthrope vise à
accroître leurs profits et leurs
influences avant tout certaines
directives sont désormais écrite par ces
lobbys et votée sans en changer une
virgule
ce déplacement du pouvoir politique vers
le pouvoir économique est inquiétant
aussi j'aimerais que le gouvernement
élève une vive protestation envers ces
pratiques acceptées par la commission
pratique et conduisent à une inflation
de directives conforme à l'esprit de
lisbonne mais particulièrement
défavorable aux peuples d'europe
merci monsieur 4 vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur courteau
je rappelle en réponse à votre question
que dès la présentation ce projet au
mois de janvier comme je l'aï indiqué
dans ma déclaration lumière le
gouvernement s'est opposé vivement à la
partie
je dis bien la partie de ce projet de
directive qui concernait le coupage du
rosé est comme gelée indiqué tout à
l'heure
comme je vous ai indiqué tout à l'heure
le reste du dossier
le reste du dossier est très important
pour l'avenir de la viticulture
française et nous en soutenons ces
orientations sur l'intégration de
copeaux sur la délocalisation et le
gouvernement a soutient le reste de ce
projet aujourd'hui donc il le soutient
en état dans la mesure où la commission
est revenu sur cette position sur la
pérennité les garanties de pérennisation
de cette mesure
et je rejoins la question de madame
bruguière je crois que si nous avons
réussi c'est parce que nous sommes
mobilisés de manière collective et je
voudrais saluer le travail de gérard
césar de la commission affaires
européennes ici au sénat qui a permis
aux côtés du gouvernement avec les
professionnels et ça me permettra de
répondre à monsieur le cam de nous
mobiliser collectivement nous alertait
d'abord et ensuite de nous mobiliser
pour avec les bons arguments convaincre
au delà de nos frontières et trouver des
alliances au niveau européen pour
permettent d'influer de peser
politiquement sur le choix de la
commission
et bien ce que nous avons fait hier qui
a permis le résultat de lundi dernier
la décision de la commission nous
continuerons à le faire
les professionnels à la suite de
l'annoncé de cette décision ont été
reçus au ministère de l'agriculture et
michel barnier continuent et continuent
à travailler de manière très étroite
avec eux et nous resterons le
gouvernement va rester extrêmement
vigilant afin que le texte qui sera
proposée au vote
à la fin du mois de juin correspondent
traduisent très fidèlement la
proposition que nous défendons
collectivement et monsieur le cas mais
je terminerai par là vous nous indiquez
que
ces pratiques de lobbying ne
correspondent pas à ce que vous
souhaitez j'aurais simplement vous dire
sans défendre d'ailleurs le mode
bruxellois de lobbying et les pratiques
qui sont faites ce que je voudrais dire
et gérard césar l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est que si nous avons été
suffisamment fort sur ce sujet comme sur
le précédent d'ailleurs nous sommes très
vigilants
c'est parce qu'il ya entre les pouvoirs
publics le gouvernement le parlement
d'étroites relations avec les
professionnels et que c'est souvent eux
qui sont capables de nous alerter de
nous d'anticiper un certain nombre de
décisions qui sont prises et tout à
l'heure monsieur biz elle a également
évoqué je crois que c'est très important
qu'il y ait des échanges entre eux ce
que vivent les professionnels au
quotidien et les mesures qui peuvent
être prises par le parlement ou par le
gouvernement monsieur césar auteur de la
question
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
moi je me réjouis aujourd'hui les
consensus qui existe par rapport à ce
problème et monsieur le ministre vous
avez rassuré en partie sur l'om c'est
parce que je suis toujours très prudent
par rapport justement à ces problèmes
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le combat
on en parlait avec hubert haenel instant
la coproduction entre la commission
européenne la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat mais aussi le
ministère et michel barnier est
également les producteurs ont permis
justement d'arriver je demande à cette
solution importante pour le devenir du
rose et donc en france et non pas du vin
rosie comme je l'exprimé le talent
heures dans mon propos donc je voudrais
me réjouir et aussi répondre à nos
collègues qui sont d'intervenir en
disant qu'aujourd'hui c'est une grande
victoire pour le monde viticole
mais quand des victoires contre nous
avions bien besoin parce que ce mariage
que nous avons connue aujourd'hui sous
la responsabilité de jean bizet par
rapport aux produits bios sonel et en
particulier les fromages permet d'avoir
une dégustation qui bien sûr suivra donc
les fromages et le rosé ce sont des
produits merveilleux qui font honneur à
la gastronomie française
bien monsieur le président rennais le
président de la commission affaires
européennes oui merci monsieur le
président mais ce ministre mes chers
collègues d'abord sur le mini je
voudrais vous remercier d'avoir répondu
aux deux questions celle posée par jean
bizet et celles posées par gérard césar
vous n'ait pas été langue de bois vous
nous avez donné de bons arguments et
c'est intéressant site souligné
symboliquement que c'est le ministre
chargé de la consommation qui a répondu
sur ces deux sujets sains de la qualité
des produits français le fromage et les
vins en général et en l'occurrence le
vin rosé en particulier je voudrais
aussi remercier tous les collègues qui
sont intervenus et qui contribue ainsi
au succès de la procédure de contrôle
qui a été initié à l'occasion de la
réforme constitutionnelle
tous les collègues sans exception ça
prouve bien que tout le monde doit se
sentir concerné par les questions
européennes
certains d'entre vous ont suggéré je
crois les deux questionnaires que je
fasse venir
pascal amis mais pas seulement sur les
questions de 20 d'une manière générale
je le ferai dès cet après-midi
j'appellerai pascal lamy pour qu'ils
puissent venir devant la commission des
affaires européennes et élargie à tous
les collègues qui seraient intéressés
par ces différents sujets alors on se
demande parfois à quoi sert le parlement
alors on sait que parlement fait des
lois en tout cas essaye de faire de
bonnes lois mais maintenant le parlement
de plus en plus va s'intéresser de très
près aux questions européennes et pas la
dernière minute quand tout est bouclé
mais le plus possible en amont et c'est
ça le rôle de la nouvelle commission des
affaires européennes que j'ai l'honneur
de présider
c'est d'être vigilent et contrôle à quoi
sert le parlement jean bizet a raison de
dire il faut maintenant que les
industriels
mais les agriculteurs que ça se disent
mais finalement le parlement ça sert à
quelque chose
au moins en tout cas sur les questions
européennes et on peut l'alerté quand
tout à coup on a des soucis
et quand on sait que il tente des choses
à bruxelles qui ne vont pas
nécessairement dans le dans le bon sens
alors ainsi donc mes chers collègues
eh bien nous avons la troisième semaine
de chaque mois une semaine de contrôler
dans la semaine de contrôle il y a le
questionnement du gouvernement sur les
questions européennes
aujourd'hui nous avons eu deux sujets
d'importance pour les consommateurs mais
aussi pour la l'identité de la france
pour la qualité de nos produits
c'est le rose et le fromage eh bien nous
aurons je peux vous dire déjà le 25 juin
de nouvelles questions européennes qui
vont concerner notamment les dames qui
s'est d'abord le congé de maternité
questions européennes n'oubliez pas et
d'autre part la publication des données
passagers dans les vols internationaux
donc ça c'est la protection de la vie
privée de chacun et c'est un sujet tout
à fait important et pour terminer je
voudrais à mon tour me réjouir bien sûr
de l'issue de cette affaire
cela montre que l'europe n'est pas
toujours soudre contre le mans ce qu'on
le dit mais pour qu'elle ne soit pas
sont encore faut-il se faire entendre et
monte et monte au créneau et que nos
interventions finalement ne sont pas
toujours inutile mais il ya aussi des
leçons à tirer de cette controverse
il est anormal dans un premier temps que
le représentant de la france ait donné
son accord à cette mesure
mandaté par qui personne finalement n'en
saura jamais rien hein
cela montre que le contrôle politique
sur ce qu'on appelle la comitologie
c'est ça c'est dans le jargon à la
comitologie n'est pas suffisant
comitologie mes chers collègues je me
rappelle ce sont ces comités
il n'y en a près de 300 chargés
d'encadrer la commune
on lorsqu'elle prend des mesures
d'exécution de la législation
communautaire
disons les décrets d'application les
circulaires ou l'est ces comités sont
composés d'experts désignés par les
états mans dans la plupart des cas les
mesures arrêtées aux communaux logés
sont techniques et ne pose pas de
problème et le travail qui est fait de
cette manière est extrêmement utile et
même indispensable
imaginons que les centaines de décisions
puis l'hiver sans peigne qui sont pris
chaque année de cette manière doivent
suivre la procédure législative
européenne serait pas possible
il y aurait évidemment un engagement
immédiat mais nous mais nous le savons
tous il n'y a pas de frontières figé
entre ce qui est technique et ce qui est
politique on pourrait dire que changer
les méthodes de production du vin rosé
c'est une question technique mais on
voit bien que quand on touche à des
traditions à une culture à l'équilibré
économique d'une filière alors la
question
la question devient en réalité politique
politique avec un grand p 1 écrit
politika qu'un type est un grand p moi
j'aime bien écrit avec un grand p c'est
pourquoi il est indispensable que nous
soyons mieux informés sur les projets
examinés et ça je m'adresse à vous
monsieur le ministre
examinée dans ces comités dans 99% des
cas il ne pose pas de problème mais il
reste quelques textes pour lesquels il
est indispensable que nous puissions
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé tant qu'il
est temps
c'est à dire avant que le comité ne se
prononce ce sont les ministères chacun
pour son compte qui suivent ces comités
il fallait donc que dans chaque
ministère sur le mini chaque fois qu'il
ya un doute sur la portée politique
éventuel d'un projet qui sera examiné en
comité au logis on prenne la peine d'en
informer le parlement il ya pas un
devoir une science cela n'est ni si dans
l'hémicycle il y à la commission des
affaires européennes ya les commissions
au fond suffirait de un coup de fil au
au président en lui disant que ce que
vous pensez de salsa puis on voit bien
quelle réaction on doit voir ou ne pas
à voir donc en conclusion je souhaite
que nous restions vigilants les uns les
autres sur cette affaire de vin rosé
car il ne faudrait pas que ce qui est
sorti par la porte revienne un jour par
la fenêtre
je remercie merci monsieur le président
je crois qui a une belle unanimité dans
cette assemblée aussi autour de ces
sujets en particulier du vin rosé